monado Mahara
Jack please welcome Natalie Spencer
Ackerman
Ackerman how you stuffed summer coast
octopus Lou that worm some Scotty in
dealers or it's novellas in literature
noble Prince it is literature or sugar
on the sexton till dealers Bob Dylan
[Applause]
noble princess noble president it
returned or Segundo Sexton tilde Alice
Bob Dylan saw scope at Nyjah buiiet
Easter Utrecht in and installer American
ska song traditional the Nobel Prize in
Literature for 2016 is awarded to Bob
Dylan for having created new poetic
expressions within the great American
song tradition Latino Bella trattoria
Kalani do Mills's at a tree be a our Bob
Dylan for our tree a dollar card de la
Granja de chillon de la musica breakin
de novo mode decks Paseo poetical the
Nobel Prize in Literature Odyssey
rs.5000 16 weird Bob Dylan
Faline design a politician noisy
opponent in the Agusan Americana Xiang
ji sang today she owned hi
[Applause]
Sahra dong use Herman secretary in the
Swedish Academy
this year's choice is radical with
startup sensation I think just Bob Dylan
really deserve a Nobel Prize why why
well avulsed Elsa just got it he is a
great poet he is a great poet in the
english-speaking tradition and he is a
wonderful sampler a very original
sampler he embodies the tradition and
for 55 54 years now he's been at it and
reinventing himself constantly
reinventing himself creating a new
identity have you talked to him today no
I haven't I will love the words he is
not a person who is who was nice and
smiling when it gets awards but that
doesn't worry no I think I have a good
message do you have personal favorites
among his songs I think that if you want
to start listening or reading you may
start with blonde on blonde with the
album from 1966 who got many classics
and it's an extraordinary example of his
brilliant way of rhyming and putting it
together refrains and his pictorial
thinking he has not written novels not
coaching the usual sense you have
widened the rice well it may look that
way but really we haven't um in a way if
you look back fall back
2500 years or so you discover homer and
Sappho and they wrote on poetic texts
that were meant to be listened to they
were meant to be performed often
together with instruments
and it's the same way with Bob Dylan but
we still read Homer and Sappho and we
enjoyed it we enjoy it and same thing
with Bob Dylan he can be read and she'll
be read and is a great poet in the
English tradition in the ground English
poetic tradition do you think there will
be criticism against the surprise I hope
not when you were young into pop rock
music which I guess you were did you
listen a lot to Bob Dylan um not really
but he was always around so I know the
music and I've started to appreciate him
much more now than I did some David
Bowie fan perhaps it's the question of
generation I don't know but today I'm a
lover of Bob Dylan I'm glad you didn't
answer Lee didn't answer the answer my
friend is blowing in the wind
this is a very changing perhaps right
thank you
you